kaitlin is on the line in Lansing
Michigan
hi Kaitlyn how are you hi Dave I'm doing
great
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
um me and my husband just got done
reading your book Total Money Makeover
and we made our first budget with every
dollar app cool and we're looking to
figure out what the best way to
jumpstart our snowball is I think we may
need to get rid of our vehicle and then
the other option would be taking the
penalty on our 401k okay that's are both
of them the 401k we do not take money
out of the 401k it says that in the
Total Money Makeover you missed that and
then of those chapters you do not cash
out retirement
unless you're avoiding a bankruptcy or
foreclosure and I don't think that's
where you are okay
the reason is this you get charged a 10%
penalty pleasure tax rate what's your
household income we bring home 5,000 a
month so your household incomes about 80
a year yep okay so you're in 25% tax
bracket that means you'll be charged
twenty-five percent plus ten percent or
thirty five percent of whatever you took
out of the 401k Dave I want to borrow
money at 35 percent interest to pay off
my debt no I would not tell you to do
that no you do not want to do that would
you
No okay so we're gonna leave the 401k
alone how much do you owe on your car 20
and what's your end you said your
household incomes 80 how much total debt
do you have not counting your house not
counting our house 160 it's just student
loans in the car okay cars not your
problem
yeah so who's the doctor yeah neither of
us which is I wish we found your
teachings when we were 18 what are your
degrees
advertising photography and and graphic
design for 160 grand a hundred grand oh
you say your hundred sixty thousand
dollars and
yes only 20 of its of cars that's 140
right yep okay all right okay so you
make 80 so 160 I mean you can sell the
car move down if you want the beauty of
that is is not only to get rid of chunk
of that but it gives you that extra four
hundred bucks a month which you're 500
bucks a month whatever your car payment
is to chunk towards this so let's see if
we did 40 a year for four years you're
debt-free not counting selling the car
it's gonna take you three years even if
you sell the car and that's what
absolutely no life and probably working
extra jobs and freelancing on everything
else on the side right yep
the good news is with your degrees I
assume you're in graphic arts and you're
in photography maybe we do have regular
nine-to-five s and we do it as a side
hustle yeah yeah you need a bunch of
side hustles right now lots and lots of
hustling on the side but you can get
there you can do it and you're gonna be
alright it's just gonna take you three
years but I'm glad you found the book
and I'm glad you're working it and if I
can help you while you're working your
way through this you call me back I
think you can do it I know you can do it
it's just a matter of man it's gonna be
it's gonna be a hard three years for
y'all beans and rice rice and beans and
stop adding to the 401 k for goodness
sakes temporarily that was also in that
book the Total Money Makeover that you
read hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh